[Musique]
là
à
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue pour ce numéro spécial
de mode d'emploi nous sommes au
vélodrome nationale à l'occasion de
l'événement en piste pour l'emploi c'est
le rendez vous de saint quentin en
yvelines dédié à l'emploi et à la
formation
focus justement sur l'évolution
professionnelle
[Musique]
nous allons nous intéresser au parcours
inspirant de deux entreprises situées
est sur notre territoire alors l'une est
basé à elancourt c'est bleu lainé a
spécialisé dans les objets connectés au
sein des établissements de santé
son président qui est juste en face de
moi laurent levasseur nous en dira plus
dans quelques minutes sur l'histoire de
cette société créée en 2006 à ses côtés
garé en sens pdg de la société all
tricks dont les bureaux sont situés à
montigny le bretonneux
on va revenir évidemment détail 1 / sur
votre ascension sur l'ascension
également de blue line et à avant gary
ans ainsi ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter votre votre société
alors all three que c'est une
plate-forme e-commerce essentiellement
aux sons commence à se développer en
est-elle physique également qui
s'adresse à des clients particuliers et
auquel on propose soixante mille
articles de sport plus précisément sur
les disciplines du vélo de la course à
pied et de là où tu as donc notre métier
c'est de d'acheter de stocker de
développer des marques en propre
maintenant et les bleus projet proposé
par don via une plateforme digitale à un
peu plus d'un million de consommateurs
et clients maintenant
chez nous donc on a on dit souvent en
interne 2 métier un métier à la fois qui
nécessite beaucoup de compétences sur la
partie sportive est un métier qu'est
tech
digital laurent levasseur également
présentation de blue line est un blue
line et est une entreprise qui est là
pour prendre soin de vos parents dans
votre cas plutôt de vos grands parents
qu'ils soient très âgées ou en situation
de handicap qu'ils soient à leur
domicile ou en établissement
concrètement on a créé une plateforme
h/24 7 sur 7 ou à la fois on traite et
on remonte des informations d'objets
connectés connecter directement sur vos
parents ou grands-parents connectés à
leur maison à leur habitat et puis on va
lorsque des alertes vont apparaître
lorsqu'on va avoir des éléments
perturbants et bien faire intervenir les
voisins
les secours et puis souvent parlé avec
eux communiquer avec eux leur apporter
du réconfort
donc voilà on a développé comme ça une
offre qui s'appelle désormais une offre
d pad à domicile
ça permet à des personnes âgées de ne
pas aller trop tôt dans une maison de
retraite
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus sur votre parcours laurent
levasseur un bon parcours
ah oui un parcours inspirant gardien
voilà sacrée mission bidon on va voir
lequel si on arrive à inspirer si on
arrive à vous inspirer
concrètement notre parcours est assez
enfin mon parcours et est assez simple
j'ai commencé deux choses en même temps
des études supérieures et une première
entreprise et du coup j'ai eu le virus
donc j'ai très vite abandonné mes études
supérieures pour développer plusieurs
entreprises depuis l'âge de 18 ans la
halle
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui je suis
présent ici c'est que je on a réussi
avec une équipe faire qu'une start-up
prometteuses devienne une entreprise
avec bien évidemment un parcours
non pas atypique mais quand on a une
start up prometteuses et quand on
développe une idée il faut très vite
trouver un modèle économique qui permet
de rencontrer un marché des clients du
chiffre d'affaires et il faut que
l'ensemble soit pérenne c'est à dire
qu'il faut que l'ensemble soit rentable
et c'est ce parcours qui fait que je me
trouve peut-être ici on a on est passé
de 6 collaborateurs à presque une
centaine en 18 mois
2-0 clients à plus de 26000 particuliers
abonnés à nos services tous les mois et
plus de 800 établissements en france qui
développe nos services on est en train
d'ouvrir une structure en allemagne
petit parcours atypique j'ai choisi de
faire coter en bourse nos linéaires pour
réussir à financer notre modèle
économique
acheté beaucoup d'objets connectés qu'on
met à disposition de personnes âgées
pour qu'elle puisse payer un abonnement
à un prix normal tous les mois sans
engagement
voilà alors pourquoi ce choix de la
silver economy
alors je ne savais pas du tout que
j'étais un acteur de silver economy
avant qu'on m'en parle
le sujet c'était surtout de prendre soin
un de vos parents vos grands parents
et puis on s'est aperçu qu'une filière
apparaissait il est vrai que on a servi
beaucoup d'illustrations à michèle
delaunay qui a été la secrétaire d'état
qui a lancé la silver economy ensuite à
monsieur macron lorsqu'il a repris ce
sujet il ya trois ans où on nous a
demandé de de coanimer avec un groupe
qui s'appelle la poste des initiatives à
l'échelle nationale et maintenant le
le sujet est un sujet de qui correspond
à une problématique pour toutes nos
familles nous vieillissons tous de plus
en plus longtemps
c'est bien de vieillir longtemps mais
c'est mieux de prolonger l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé et c'est là dessus
qu'on travaille le plus on parlera
évidemment tout à l'heure des objets
notamment que vous proposez gary à mon
sens je crois que tout a commencé dans
un garage pour vous effectivement ça a
démarré dans le garage de mon père au
men et saint denis or j'ai une histoire
assez similaire à la vôtre
la mesure où j'ai mon parcours assez
classique aussi scolaire si ce n'est
qu'à l'âge de 20 ans j'ai fait une chute
assez grave en vélo je pratique en
compétition je me suis cassé la colonne
donc j'ai assez long beaucoup de moi à
l'hôpital
j'ai dû arrêter les cours et après un an
de rééducation j'ai décidé de retourner
sur les bancs de l'école et en étant à
l'école j'ai monté ma première
entreprise et je faisais ma comptabilité
en cours et en même temps j'ai essayé
d'écouter puis un moment j'ai fait un
choix et j'ai quitté les courts dont
j'ai ma première entreprise a été lancé
j'avais 21 ans
j'en ai 34 maintenant j'en ai eu deux
précédentes avants all tricks et donc
aux tricks été lancé en 2008 comme vous
le soulignez tout à l'heure et nous on
arrive un peu en amont par rapport à
vous nous on essaye de faire en sorte de
démocratiser un maximum le sport pour
que les gens vivent plus longtemps et
que vous puissiez les accompagner
derrière cette complémentaire finalement
ce choix de ce secteur donc du vélo
c'est évidemment parce que le vélo c'est
une passion pour vous en faites moi
par rapport aux difficultés que j'ai
rencontrées suite à mon accident j'ai
fait preuve de mobilité donc le modèle
du e-commerce c'était quand même assez
génial à l'époque en 2003 quand je me
suis lancée par rapport à ça parce qu'on
pouvait monter un commerce de chez soi
la vraie target c'était d'être alors à
la poste pour chiper les colis mais vous
êtes ans chez vous en charentaises si
vous décrochez au téléphone et que vous
avez un peu d'aplomb et un discours pro
personne c'est que vous êtes en pyjama
ou pas très bien et donc j'ai développé
les premières activités comme ça et on
recommencera faire un peu de sport
après je me suis dit bon c'est vrai que
c'est un marché qui est assez sympa le
sport est en plein boom
on s'est diversifiée nous maintenant il
ya trois ans sur le la course à pied
également il ya plus de 12 millions
d'euros nord en france et la moitié de
ces gens là ne pourrait pas il ya deux
ans donc on est sur des marchés qui sont
en plein essor qui affichent de belles
croissances sur les différents secteurs
et donc je suis à lyon les deux alors
c'est vrai qu'on est sur des productions
à cette technique ce qu'on est sur du
moyen et haut de gamme avec des niveaux
de prix on vend des vélos jusqu'à 10000
euros
donc il ya parfois une notion de j'ai
envie de le voir j'ai envie de l'essayer
notion de taille qui n'est pas toujours
évidente à gérer sur un modèle
e-commerce
c'est pour ça qu'on développe un peu la
marque en omni canal maintenant pour
autant vous le soulignez tout à l'heure
on voit là ont fait 56 millions de
chiffre d'affaires après huit ans on
expliquer un peu plus un million et demi
de pièces et d'accessoires de vélo
l'année dernière depuis nos propres
entrepôts et avec une base de clients
proche du million qui est très très
communautaire et rêche règne autour de
la marque
des chiffres qui font qu'ils font rêver
hein vous étiez seul au départ pour
quand vous avez pensé voilà ce site de
e-commerce hall tricks oui alors j'ai
dans une ma deuxième entreprise était
associé
on toujours en phase sur le plan de la
stratégie
je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas s'associe
bien au contraire ce que je le suis dans
d'autres entreprises par ailleurs
aujourd'hui ça se passe très très bien
mais ça je suis reparti sur le trx au
sol avec cette idée en tête et puis
c'est pas facile mais une fois qu'on a
affronté les premières difficultés bon
on se on se forge des couches de
carapace incrémentale qui qui se font et
voilà je regarde pas là on en parlait un
peu tout à l'heure nous on est pas on
n'est pas sur le marché boursier
on s'est penché sur cette solution là un
moment et puis on a finalement décidé
parce qu'on avait sans doute le fait que
je sois seul besoin aussi d'être entouré
et en fait on a fait trois levées de
fonds sur les dix dernières années
auprès très beau fond on a un
accompagnement aussi une sorte de
manteaux ring avec des gens qui ont vu
les normands de dossiers donc c'est
assez intéressant d'entourer par les
administrateurs j'ai une dizaine
d'actionnaires aujourd'hui au capital
laurent levasseur vous étiez seul quand
vous avez
pour l'épauler pour les débuts de blue
line r non j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un
mentor dès le début et il en était le
président j'en étais le dg et
aujourd'hui il est le président du
conseil surveillance et moi je suis le
président du directoire et donc c'est
très important de d'accepter le partage
d'expériences d'accepter de d'échangés
on n'a jamais changé un seul tableau
excel entre nous n'était pas nécessaire
pour lui ni pour moi car on avait tous
ces chiffres en tête en permanence mais
c'était et on savait qu on faisait le
maximum des deux côtés donc ce n'est pas
la peine de partager un feu ne louent ou
d où des prévisions qui forcément
étaient fausses au début de mon parcours
j'ai aussi levé on a levé un peu
d'argent mais après avoir constitué et
crée l'offre et tous les business plans
ils sont toujours faux est la seule
chance que vous devez avoir c'est que le
business man soit faux dans le bon sens
que vous allez au delà de ce que vous
aviez prévu mais en même temps les gens
qui investissent dans votre entreprise
ils savent déjà que ça va être plus long
que prévu ils savent déjà que
la voie est tracée mais on ne sait pas
vraiment à quelle vitesse vous allez
franchir les étapes ça ils sont déjà au
courant
vous vous êtes convaincus vous ferez
mieux que tout le monde est plus
rapidement que tout le monde et puis
après vous être rattrapés par la réalité
concrètement ce qu'il faut surtout
retenir c'est que dans le développement
d'une entreprise
vous avez une idée la mettre en forme
réussir à ce qu' elle soit après
fédératrice auprès de collaborateurs
d'une équipe
et puis qu'on arrive à monter en
compétences et qu'on arrive aussi avoir
une traçabilité tout la mise en place
quand vous avez un million et demi de
colis qui son union et demi de pièces
qui sont envoyées ces vous tenez plus
c'est le son métier est devenu générique
c'est de la logistique c'est
l'acquisition c'est du suivi et est
globalement ça pourrait être n'importe
quoi et mais ça fonctionne ainsi
c'est ça on est complètement d'accord
voilà est bon pour mon pour ma part
c'est la même chose
oui avoir une relation il des délégués
du personnel une inspectrice du travail
la mise en place du travail âge 24 ce
genre de protocoles et puis fédérer les
équipes gérer le taux d'implication des
personnels et bien c'est toute une série
de sujets auxquels on n'est pas du tout
programmé au départ
au départ on est star tupper n'a une
idée on est tout neuf on pense que ça
suffira
et après il faut s'adapter alors dans le
développement de votre entreprise est ce
que vous avez connu des difficultés
ah oui mon entreprise a failli
disparaître l'année dernière d'un taux
de croissance de 9 100 %
vous passez vous franchissez la barre
des 100 personnes et puis vous avez ce
qui s'appelle un dispositif en place en
france qui se met le crédit d'impôt
recherche et pendant des années vous
vous déclarez un crédit d'impôt
recherche vous développer des offres
vous avez des contrôles et puis un jour
il ya un contrôle qui se passent pas
comme les autres simplement parce que
vous avez déplacer votre siège vous
tombez sur une nouvelle équipe qui a
besoin de tout comprendre depuis le
début et puis quand vous êtes sur un
secteur où vous mélangez la e-santé du
social s'est passé compliqué de trouver
les experts qui vont audit est votre
projet et donc j'ai failli perdre
l'entreprise ont fait une campagne télé
sur france 2 france 3 fin 2016
on a 32 % de croissance à nouveau
l'entreprise va bien
les commandes affluent et puis vous
recevez un courrier qui vous explique
que vous allez devoir quasiment
remboursé un tiers de votre chiffre
d'affaires annuel pour gary ce serait
l'équivalent de 20 millions d'euros
donc forcément ça réveille et comme vous
êtes cotées en bourse
eh bien il faut informer tous vos petits
porteurs que healy a potentiellement
dans six mois un mur qui va tomber
devant vous et quand ça se produit
eh bien mon papa m'avait expliqué qu'on
perdait la confiance plus vite qu'on la
gagne est donc en 48 heures l'entreprise
a perdu la moitié de sa valeur en bourse
c'est normal et puis au bout de six mois
de conversation et bien nous avons eu
gain de cause à 100% intérêts moratoires
compris donc par rapport à ces 20
millions ça ferait un peu près 4
millions et demi d'euros
donc c'est beaucoup d'argent et on vous
dit à ben vous aviez raison c'était
c'était vrai ce que vous faisiez et là
vous mettez plusieurs semaines à
rétablir la situation
malheureusement pendant ce temps là vous
avez préparé la structure a un impact
vous l'avez préparer à se dire et si
jamais on ne m'entendait pas et donc
vous avez réduit les effectifs optimiser
les effectifs de 25 %
vous avez préparé à ce que l'entreprise
plus vive
pire et le pire n'est pas arrivé et
quand j'ai averti nos actionnaires une
marche et que nous étions sortis
d'affaires je peux vous assurer que j'ai
rencontré tous mes collaborateurs 10 par
dix et on a échangé sur ce qu'eux
avaient vécu et sur ce que j'ai vécu et
on a c'était un peu des séances de
psychologie groupe mais ça a fait du
bien à tout le monde pourquoi il était
encore là pourquoi la boîte avait
préparé un impact qui n'a pas eu lieu
et pourquoi on allait être déterminé à
réussir encore plus parce que c'était
pas juste voilà
mais ça fait partie de la vie d'un
entrepreneur vous avez de plus en plus
de clients il faut aussi gérer le
quotidien la gestion les finances gary
encenser ce que justement vous aussi ça
fait partie de votre votre quotidien
d'entrepreneurs ces difficultés vous les
avez connus
oui bien sûr alors j'allais dire avec le
sourire les difficultés on en a tous et
c'est presque pour ça qu'on fait ça
aussi c'est ce challenge quotidien qui
fait qu'on est animé votre
d'entrepreneurs alors qu'ils sont moins
amusante que d'autres à gérer nous on a
eu un effet de seuil de croissance il ya
deux ans aussi je l'entreprise n'est pas
passé loin aussi de sa fin et c'est
assez dingue parce qu'en fait on a
failli être victime de notre croissance
on a on a grandi très vite sur les 2015
on a recruté 40 ou 50 personnes
on a notre entrepôt qui est arrivé au
bout de ses capacités on a déménagé neuf
fois en dix ans donc on va déménager sur
cette année plusieurs fois tellement
s'agrandissent et vite
et en fait on a eu à la fois
sur la partie collaborateurs on et 130
140 aujourd'hui c'est un réel challenge
quotidien pour nous on est effectivement
plus une start up dans la définition
cadrait du terme mais on vole l'être
dans l'esprit est de faire rentrer d'une
bordée des nouveaux collaborateurs
chaque année avec des gens qui vous ont
connu quand on était 5 et où l'on
déjeuné avec des boîtes de pizza sur les
claviers pour finir les journées à 23
heures et puis des personnes qui
arrivent maintenant on a un c'est eux on
a un chsct etc
réussir à venir regarder cette même
mentalité avec évidemment la structure
qui doit aller avec une entreprise de
notre taille maintenant ça c'est un vrai
challenge quotidien et donc sur cette
même année on a dû changer notre site
internet parce qu'il était au bout de
ses capacités on a dû doubler donc passé
de 9 mm un peu près doublé
dix sept mille mètres carrés d'entrepôts
le mécanisée on a eu trois cadeaux des
autorités sur la même année contrôle
fiscal des nécessaires et inspection du
travail
donc voilà c'est le quotidien des
entrepreneurs aussi en france moi je
suis arrivé au mois d'août en vacances
genou au sol et je me suis dit bon
qu'est ce que je fais
et parce que je suis un entrepreneur pu
repartir au boulot et on est sortis de
cette phase là et je pense qu'on est 20
fois plus solide maintenant mais c'est
le quotidien 'aujourd'hui hall tricks
c'est qu'elle marchait marché français
marché européen marchés à
l'international ses 83 % en france et
ses 17% d'export à ses frontaliers on
est le deuxième plus gros marché c'est
l'espagne et après on est assez présent
en italie en allemagne et vous monsieur
levasseur un brûlot n'ya aujourd'hui
c'est surtout français on commence à
regarder comment avec la nos
actionnaires nous développer en
allemagne et bien évidemment on a des
sollicitations de différents autres pays
européens mais on y va doucement parce
que justement on est encore sur un
modèle où on veut éprouver tous nos
dispositifs pour éviter ces nouvelles
crises de croissance
justement votre ex de développement vous
c'est l'ehpad à domicile parce que pour
nous expliquer ce concept 83% des
français ne rêve pas du tout d'aller
dans un ehpad 83% des français soient
d'hier le plus longtemps possible chez
elles cédé face chez eux c'est tout à
fait normal et compréhensible et par
contre il faut quand même gérer ça vous
avez tous 20 ans de moins que vos
parents au même âge une personne de 70
ans il ya vingt ans n'était ce n'est pas
du tout la même aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui elle voyage a relevé sa vie
échange de deux dates de logements et
change de vie il ya vingt ans c'était
une personne qui était très âgé dans
l'esprit de chacun pourquoi je vous
raconte ça c'est la vie de nos familles
et concrètement on a décidé de mettre en
place suffisamment de solutions qui
permettent d'accompagner un senior une
personne âgée un couple le plus
longtemps possible chez eux et avec on a
d'abord le domicile avec de la domotique
en mettant en place aussi des solutions
de type détection de chute bracelet pour
personnes âgées meurent ou autres
dispositifs bouton d'appel ajointe 4
pour en permanence les accompagner votre
cible les particuliers les
professionnels alors dont nos clients
sont leurs enfants qui ont entre 50 et
70 ans et qui avec nous imagine une
solution pour leurs parents qui ont 20
ans de plus voilà et on a aujourd'hui
les deux tiers de nos clients en direct
et un tiers via des partenaires qui
peuvent être des groupes de protection
sociale des banques des assurances et
mutuelles
mais chez nous on dit pas qu'on ne fait
du bit ou si on fait du site ou bi c'est
le bouche à oreille mais je pense que
garry dorr à peu près la même chose
justement gardien on sait ce qu'est ce
qu'on retrouve sur le site all tricks
l'autre tout l'équipement pour pratiquer
donc le vélo la course à pied ou
l'outdoor donc évidemment ça va sur sa
part du vélo complet tous les
accessoires qu'il faut pour le monter ou
l'entretenir l'équipement qu'il faut
pour le pratiquer donc on part de la
chaussure jusqu'au casque et puis tout
ce qui vient en accessoires aussi
aujourd'hui donc les produits connectés
aussi est-ce qu'on est dans un monde qui
est très connectée qui est très
communautaire où il ya de la partage de
tata sur les réseaux sociaux
on a beaucoup de pratiquants geek aussi
aujourd'hui il ya tout l'aspect
nutrition
et puis on commence à proposer de
l'offre dématérialisée au 6e
ont typiquement alors on l'annoncé ce
soir j'ai un petit teaser la fédération
française de cyclisme qui est installée
ici au vélodrome va commencer à
commercialiser ses licences sur all
tricks à partir de demain
donc on pourra vendre du dématérialisé
on va commencer à vendre des assurances
de vélo on va commencer à vendre des
voyages mais perso je ne 70 aussi en
ligne et donc l'idée c'est vraiment
créer une destination pour les sportifs
où on est capable de proposer une
palette de services et de produits
et quand je dis servi ça va bien plus
loin que ça c'est en collectant de la
data sur ça qu'on a aimé ticket traitait
qu'aussi aujourd'hui qu'un produits
connectés une montre on est capable de
savoir exactement qui les kilométrages
parcourus par un sportif si nous
autorise à partager cette date à la on
peut mieux le conseiller sur les
produits dont il a besoin sur la
périodicité et c'est donc vrai relais
sur le plan commercial aussi
communautaire etc qui sont qui sont très
sympas et donc voilà c'est notre métier
est la promesse pour pour conclure un
peu cette parenthèse c'est que on a 60
mille produits qui sont stockés chez nos
60000 référence c'est plus précisément
sept cent mille produits
et qui sont disponibles en permanence
dès lors recommandé chez nous avant 18h
vous êtes libre le lendemain à 9h les
centres en france en italie en espagne
en allemagne
donc on est une promesse qui est très
très forte et on est dans un effet waouh
et je rebondirai sur ce que vous évoquez
parce qu'effectivement nous le bouche à
oreille on connaît bien et quand vous
êtes en plus sur un marché encore une
fois qui est communautaire où les
sportifs ont cette tendance à pratiquer
en groupe
si vous êtes bon dans votre job vous
avez la chance qu'on parle de voir si
vous êtes mauvais ça ça marche aussi
mais si vous êtes bon ça fonctionne
laurent levasseur quels sont vos
objectifs pour blue line et à dans un an
dans deux ans je sais pas comment il
faut compter est ce que vous êtes fixé
vous fixez j'imagine de toute façon
toujours des objectifs
ouais mais comment les côtés en bourse
sont les communique pas on a fait ce
choix et comme ça on peut que surprendre
mais vaut mieux surprendre du bon côté
concrètement que l'on puisse aujourd'hui
on accompagne plus de 25000 personnes
âgées
là où il ya à peu près deux millions de
personnes qui devraient accompagner
souvent vos cite en exemple parce qu'il
ya très peu d'entreprises qui ont trouvé
un modèle économique sur le
vieillissement sur les personnes âgées
quand on est malade on sait comment ça
se passe on arrive aux anges dans
l'hôpital yade mutuel il ya une carte
d'assurance maladie
mais quand on est âgé c'est une autre
histoire et concrètement notre vocation
à nous c'est dommage accompagné plutôt
200 300 500 mille personnes dans ce
modèle plutôt que 26000 on dit que c'est
vachement bien
mais franchement c'est pas grand chose
il ya encore beaucoup à faire
gary encense vos objectifs pour holt
rixe notre objectif de donc c'est se
développer sur l'a20 terry tel physique
comme on l'est comme on l'évoqué tout à
l'heure continuer notre développement
international
tu peux la force qu'on a nous c'est
qu'on a on a un produit qui in fine et
on vend beaucoup de vélo mais notre plus
grand métier c'est de vente de
l'accessoire de la pièce détachée nous
appelle souvent le petit oscar ou du
vélo et le petit oscar ou du vélo son
collier moyens il fait la taille d'une
boîte de chaussures il fait 2 kg et donc
de la région parisienne de france
on peut expédier dans tous les pays en
24 48 heures sans ouvrir des succursales
donc on a quand même de vrais à 7 pour
pouvoir développer la partie
internationale
et puis et puis après ça on a un projet
qu'on vient de lancer qui qui s'appelle
connect on vient accueillir maintenant
des vendeurs tiers sur notre plateforme
oak tous les magasins de france
maintenant peuvent venir proposer leurs
offres directement sur vos tricks
marketplace et profiter dès 2011
visiteurs que nous avons mensuellement
merci merci en tout cas pour pour vos
témoignages et j'imagine des témoignages
qui ont certainement susciter des
vocations dans le public merci à tous
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à très bientôt pour un
nouveau mode d'emploi
[Musique]
à